i'm done i don't want to have anything
to do with it i'm just back off so i
can't wait
come on come here come here come on no
no no please
come here please wait you i see you i'm
gonna beat you up
a sway little sister could not control
her temper
and if it wasn't brazuelu's mom holding
her back
according to kalani it would have went
down
if your sister would have touched my
body i would have dropped her period
kalani is not playing any games and look
this money situation between asuelu and
his family
is honestly getting to a point where
he just might lose his wife i do feel
like i
love him still i just feel like every
day it's getting less and less
and i feel like if it keeps continuing
on like this
i won't want to be a part of this
marriage anymore
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
the latest episode of happily ever after
it was a lot to say the least if you
thought a potential fight between kalani
and asuelu's sister was
over the top just wait until you see
what shenzhen and tanya
have been up to so do you want to be
with me
you need to take a step down before we
get into that
let me give you a full update on what's
going on between kalani and asuelu
starting from the top asuelu's family is
still
pressing him about the thousand dollars
that his mom
is requesting just give me money that's
all i want
so kalani decided to meet with them
alone
to try to get them to understand once
again why
giving that amount of money is just
it's not an option for her family what
money is he supposed to give you
because if he's giving all this money
that he doesn't have then he's going to
be poor
he's not going to be boy you guys live
with your parents
they can support and help you or you
know you can work to
so you can be able both of you to help
our family back home
do you get it or you just don't want to
be you don't want to work you're lazy
right
wow so i'm lazy because i don't want to
work to give you guys free money not
take care of
us all my mom wants us well to help our
family back on the sidewalk
honestly i'm surprised kalani kept her
cool up until this point
but just wait this conversation is about
to take an
even crazier turn girl you got pregnant
from my brother
if we tell you to go get pregnant no
that is your own part because you want
to marry as well when
as well to be your husband this is just
the craziest thing yet
i can't believe that they're accusing me
of getting pregnant on purpose as if i
swell it was just this amazing catch
when i've never
asked anything of him so it's just kind
of weird for them to accuse me of things
when they're the ones that keep asking
me for money
i have nothing because i swear we will
i'll pay you what you say
instead of mom i'm sorry clanny
i don't care about the kids wow i mean
we knew that but i just never thought
she would admit it
now this is when the conversation really
started to get heated
aswell's mom said that she wanted to
take asuelu back to samoa
and his sister told kalani that she
should consider
a divorce and then she accused her of
brainwashing her brother
you brainwash as well
you're too old for him you control him
all i've done is love us that's why i
don't like you
i don't care what anyone else thinks of
me
he had nothing when we met and i loved
him so i i apologize for loving oswalo
and having it have nothing to do with
money i really am so sorry
i can't
why are you crying kalani because of the
way you brainwash and control as well
yeah she's missing the point obviously
but after that comment kalani she just
felt like it was best for her
to walk away i'm done i don't want to
have anything to do with it
i'm just back off so i can't wait come
on come on
come here come here come on no no no
please come here please
wait you i see you i'm gonna peel you up
these people are just nuts i'm done like
i can't do this anymore
i can't do it kalani went home to tell
asuelu what happened
and at first he was sympathizing with
her
whoa so now they step from like level
one to
level 17. yes that's not the level that
they should reach
but then he started to debate her about
who would have won
the fight if she would have grabbed me i
would have knocked her out so you think
that
if my sister will touch her you can
knock her out oh do i think that or is
that what i would do
oh i would do that what about my sister
knocked you up
no i've beaten up people bigger than
your sister in the third
grade so no if you try to do that my
sister will not
knock out okay so now we're debating who
would win in a fight
right and as you probably assumed this
little back and forth
it turned into a full on argument
thank you you're a
family i think you're crazy
let's just move on to our next must-see
moment
shall we if it's something you think you
want to do
go try it out you haven't even tried it
out
just try it believe me i've tried so
much in my life that's what makes my
life amazing
i've known you oh my god over dinner
tanya and sanjin just aired all of their
dirty laundry out
and i mean all of it in front of
senjen's family
they went from arguing about potentially
moving to south africa
to arguing about having kids and then
they started to argue about sinjin's
lack of structure but how long do i wait
and when is it
when is it unfair to him for me to give
up or when is it unfair to me to keep
waiting
like what is that healthy balance yeah i
think what you should do is maybe just
step back and let syndrome also
yeah but then that that she doesn't see
focusing though it doesn't take too much
time but that's where trust comes in
what have i done the past two years like
literally
i've left him and when i left him you
know what he did he went and drank and
partied with friends
you watch it a lot now yeah as usual
at this point i just don't see the
compatibility
between these two at all i really would
be interested to see how
their relationship is going to pan out
in the years to come
something else that i'm really
interested in seeing pan out is
kalani and asuelo's relationship next
week
he was just saying all this like crazy
stuff and just like acting not like his
typical self i can't keep living like
this things that are be done
marriage should be about supporting each
other and about being happy and
that's not what i have right now all
right 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with e.t because we
are covering it all i'll see you next
[Music]
time